ANTON CHUVAKIN: Hello,
and welcome to scale-up
your security telemetry.
This is Anton Chuvakin with
Google Cloud and Chronicle.
I want to highlight
some of the challenges
and some of the solutions
that organizations
face in their battles
to optimize and improve
their security operations
and improve their detection.
I want to start
with trying to give
a bit of a landscape around
threats, security operations,
and highlight some of the
things that matter today.
A lot of the things we
encounter in this space
are artifacts of
the past errors.
We have to deal with issues
that are inherited by companies
and that have been
dealt with for years.
However, there are
also new things
that our predecessors
doing security operations
have not seen.
I also wanted to highlight
the role of the cloud
as both something to monitor,
somewhere to detect threats
in, and also an enabler for
modern security operations.
And then next I wanted to
cover the details there
on Chronicle, the modern
security analytics
platform that gathers some of
the advantages of the cloud
to enable you to detect threats
in both on premise and cloud
environments.
Afterwards, I want
to highlight some
of the practical
recommendations that you
can follow whether you are
a Chronicle customer or not.
Now, why do so many
security presentations start
from a threat landscape?
To me, I do that
because I want to get
on the same page with everybody.
I wanted to highlight
some of the things
we see with other organizations
and some of the challenges you
face today.
Now, every security
presentation that I've seen,
almost every one I've
seen in my entire career,
starts from a
discussion of badness.
Maybe hackers, intrusion,
breaches, crimeware.
The words may change, but
the approach does not.
Ultimately, the
security profession
is driven by the threat.
We are driven by what the bad
guy is trying to throw at us.
In that sense, security is a
unique domain of knowledge.
A lot of the things
we do in security
are quite different
to what's done in IT
because much of what
we do is about dealing
with what an outsider, a
threat actor, or malware is
about to throw this way.
Why is it like this?
What are some of the
things that would
happen in the near future?
Now, some of you
may think, hey, it's
a painfully obvious question.
This is a domain of security.
We protect against hackers,
attackers, malware, all that.
However, there is actually a
specific reason, in my opinion,
as to why it's the case.
Now, our world, unfortunately,
looks like this.
This is my very
unscientific visual
that shows changes in the number
of security analysts, security
engineers, security
professionals in general,
and the amount of stuff,
amounts of technology that
needs securing.
Think, those of you who started
your security career many years
ago probably remember
the time when
you had to secure servers
in a data center, maybe web
servers, maybe file servers,
and essentially nothing else.
This was, perhaps,
in the late '90s
or maybe even
before that for some
of the more enlightened
ones of you.
Now, today we face a fairly
dizzying array of technologies
to secure from, well, the same
servers, going all the way back
to mainframes and technologies
that predate servers,
going all the way back
to '80s or maybe '70s.
But we also have
cloud computing,
mobility, we have
internet of things,
we have all the
analytics pipelines.
We have the emergent AI.
We have a lot of technologies
within the domain
of digital technology,
spanning IT and OT, Operational
Technology, control systems,
and IoT, Internet of Things.
In essence, what we have today--
and we will expect to
continue having this--
is that the number
of technologies,
systems, things to
secure will keep growing.
And most everybody
agrees that it
would keep growing faster than
the number of security people.
So many of the
challenges with breaches,
badness, alert overload, missed
attacks stem from the fact
that we just don't
have enough people.
So what can possibly
be done to help it?
You can automate things.
But we'll touch on this.
But the problem is that this
is the world we live in.
And in this world, we do
have an increasing amount
of things we have to secure.
How do we ever hope
to win the battle?
We'll talk about it.
Now, in many presentations,
people talk about threats.
And today I wanted to kind
of offer my own spin on this
and say these are popular
security incident types.
Now, admittedly,
in recent years,
ransomware have
become a big thing.
And it's been a
good number of years
since it became the
scourge that it is now.
Phishing attacks continue to be
a big part of modern security
incidents.
If you look at any
industry reports that
cover items that were involved
in breaches and attacks,
phishing will almost
always make an appearance.
Now, the data
theft, whether it's
payment data, valuable corporate
data, private citizens' data,
is still there.
While ransomware is
a type of malware,
we still see a fair number of
other malware, web malware,
traditional viruses and trojans.
Service attacks continue
to be interesting.
And this is the
types of attacks I've
dealt with in my past
life as an analyst.
The interesting
bit about this is
that while some consider
it to be a nuisance,
others consider it now a
service to their business
[INAUDIBLE] attack.
Now, to me, I hesitate
when I put insider threats
on any kind of a top
popular list of attacks.
I do see organizations
that are deeply concerned
with insider threat.
And these may be well in
the cloud or on premise.
Insider threat continues
to be more of a low burning
issue for some, but
there are organizations
that are quite heavily
focused on insider threat.
So I wanted to
highlight as number six
my unauthorized access and
insider threat challenges.
So to me this is
the list of things
that keeps modern chief security
officers asleep at night
or maybe nervous during the day.
Now, there may be other
threats and issues
that you deal with in your
business or in your industry,
but these are kind of
top popular issues.
And if you're doing
the monitoring,
if you're doing security
operations planning,
you're probably focusing
somewhere on these issues.
Now, the spectrum of attacks
does go all the way up.
And, of course, there are rare
but highly damaging attacks.
All the so-called state
sponsored or just top tier
cybercrime actors.
There is a type of a threat
that it shows up in, well,
in the news for sure sometimes,
in organizational security
monitoring dashboards.
But threats that,
for example, target
Google, going back many
years ago, many of them
are top tier threats.
So while we talk
about popular threats,
the reason I want
to show this slide
is while you may fight
malware every day,
it will probably be useful
to keep aware of the top tier
threat actors that
are very much human
and not automated--
and not automated
systems that can be good
at computers and at people.
In essence, when you
focus on popular threats,
don't forget that there
is a type of a threat that
may affect your
organizations that's very far
out, or up, from that spectrum.
This reminder will help
us to contextualize
some of the security analytics
requirements we'll get to.
Now, security operations
challenges specifically,
challenges that SOCs
deal with, very often
focus on these things I
highlighted in the slide.
Now, if you recall the
slide with a visual,
with my linear
graph, you do realize
that keep acquiring and keeping
talented people to do security
operations is challenging.
Now, there are many other
things that come up.
Obviously there's the growth
of spectrum, technologies,
complexity of IT, mixture
of new and old IT,
addition of OT and IoT, all puts
additional stress to security
operations.
Now, number five
on that slide is
kind of self-inflicted,
because in many cases,
in my experience, security teams
and security operations teams
aren't really friends with
some IT operations teams.
Now, at mature, enlightened
organizations, they are.
But in some of the mainstream
organizations, they are not.
Think patching, think
asset management,
think DevOps challenges.
Security in IT does have an
occasional friction point.
To me these are
important to consider
when you're planning
threat detection
and monitoring those
security operations.
Now, one thing to note is
that many of these challenges
are similar, at least
philosophically, conceptually
similar, to what we
had 5 or 10 years ago,
but they're definitely bigger.
There's a lot more IT.
There's a lot more
security tools,
because there are more alerts.
And there is a lot
more of the opinion
that we should deploy the
latest technology rather
than to refine and
improve operations.
I think that's enough of
the landscape, frankly.
I think that I presented
a few slides here
to kind of get on the same
page with the audience in terms
of what an organization
may deal with.
Now, cloud computing, by
the way, as I promised,
highlights and shows
up as both something
to monitor systems deployed
in the cloud, micro services,
other cloud components,
but also as an enabler
of security monitoring.
That's where we
get to Chronicle.
Now, you may not like
another challenges slide,
but I wanted to present
this particular visual
to kind of highlight the
comparison between how
Chronicle Security Analytics
platform is built versus some
of the existing tools.
I can call them legacy.
I would say in IT security, if
something is more than 10 years
old, it's definitely legacy.
The idea is some of
the technologies that
are born before the cloud are a
little bit difficult to scale,
or they may scale physically,
but they would not
scale economically.
And at the same time,
there are always
challenges with telemetry,
types of data being incomplete.
Now, when we are deploying
a security monitoring
tool in 2020, we
would be seeing things
that didn't exist 5
years ago, 10 years ago.
And to me, this
matters because I
want to focus on detecting
the popular threats,
but also I want to focus on
detecting the modern threats.
I want my security
analytics platform
to grow with the threats.
And I think that's
occasionally missing
from the traditional tools.
So enough of that.
I want to go deeper
into Chronicle
to highlight some of the
advantages of our approach.
Now, many companies,
many organizations
deploy with a mission statement
or with a high level vision.
Many of them are
somewhat generic.
I wanted to briefly
point at the Chronicle
vision of building a
planet-scale system for storing
and analyzing
enterprise telemetry
and making it useful for
detection hunting and response.
Now, this to me is very crisp.
And to me, when I joined
Chronicle and then ultimately
Google Cloud, that was a big
part of that [INAUDIBLE]..
Because to me, as
an analyst, I wanted
to look at things that scale,
that scale economically,
that cover modern use cases,
can cover traditional use cases,
and can also cover many of the
security operations challenges.
Detecting, nowadays threat
hunting, responding to issues.
So to me this is
a way to do that.
Chronicle to me is a way
to build a modern security
analytics platform
rather than just
to try evolving a SIEM slowly.
That matters.
Some of you in the
audience may have
deployed security
information event management
tools, or SIEMs, for a
good number of years.
And there's a long history of
fairly challenging deployment
scenarios as we learned
from the previous slide.
I wanted to build--
we wanted to build a platform
that's easy, it's deployable,
and it does leverage
unique Google assets
like threat intelligence
and, of course, search speed.
No debate here.
Now, I want to briefly
attract your attention
to the architecture
of the platform.
Now, those of you who have seen
security information and event
management tools,
log management tools,
may recognize some
of the components.
I wanted to point at some
things that are different.
Now, for the SIEM tools
that are built in the '90s
or in the early 2000s,
threat detection
and instant investigation
and, of course,
a few other use cases
that are essential,
threat hunting,
however, was not.
Chronicle is one of the few
SIEMs built with threat hunting
as a first-class use
case for a platform.
It's kind of a
group of use cases
rather, not just one use case.
So to me, the ability to
search and rapidly pivot
and refine signals while
you're doing, while you're
pursuing a pretty subtle or
a thin indicator of an attack
is important.
And I don't want to just
rely on search or on reports
or on rule-based
detection for doing that.
I want my interactive
and pivoting search
platform that's instant.
There are a few other things
that are interesting here.
Chronicle makes certain types
of telemetry like DNS and DHCP
logs to also be a
first-class data source.
Now, I've dealt with
SIEMs for-- at this point,
for almost 20 years-- for
18 years, to be exact.
And at this point, I've
seen people not put DNS, not
put DHCP logs, not put
file hashes in their SIEMs
because they are
just overwhelmed.
In case of Chronicle, you
would want to put this data in,
and it would not
cost you anything.
I'll get to the costing
point in a second.
Of course, today's
security operations
is unthinkable
without heavy reliance
on threat intelligence.
In case of Chronicle,
you would have,
if you have your
own threat intel,
you have public sources--
some of them are more
noisier than others--
all their threat intel data
flows into the platform
without any challenges, and
it would cross-correlated
to logs in a few ways.
I'll explain that
in the next slide.
Now, this slide is probably
more useful to people
who have dealt with threat
detection, security monitoring,
threat investigation challenges,
and/or deployed similar tools.
I wanted to hit a
few points here,
some in more detail than others.
First, even though
I'm a technologist,
I want to start with
disruptive economics.
Now, what does disruptive
economics really mean?
Today, it means a pricing model
for a security monitoring tool
that's different.
Now, some of you are
used to seeing tools
that deploy and price based
on data volume collected,
or the number of data sources,
the number of log sources,
or on the number of
components deployed.
There is a lot of complexity.
And of course, there is also
a charge for data retention
if you're storing data
for a year, for example.
So Chronicle launched with a
pricing model that runs off
the number of employees.
People, not data sources,
not data points, not events
per second.
Now, this means that you have
fully predictable pricing.
And predictable just means,
if you're a large company,
you count your employees,
and that's the price.
Now, this is
incredibly liberating,
let me tell you that,
for a security solution.
The reason for that
is that a lot of tools
are prized by data volume
or some derivative of that.
And that means you have
to balance your security
requirements with the fear that
you would overrun the license,
you'd incur costs.
And in case of
Chronicle, you kind of
pay a fixed price per year.
And by the way, that
fixed price includes
one year of log retention.
Not 30 days, not 90 days,
not 180 days, a full year.
And you can pay
the same, and you'd
get data retained
for more than that.
To me this is also
an important point.
Now, keeping data for
a year isn't that hard.
It's expensive for some other
people, but it's not hard.
Now, how about searching
across petabytes
of data on subsecond speed?
I'm going to move into the
bottom item on the slide.
Admittedly, very
few people at Google
are impressed by search speed
because, hey, Google can search
internet at the same speed.
Now, in the security operations
threat detection space,
instantaneous searches
over petabytes
of data just aren't that common,
or in fact, if they do happen
to somebody, it's usually at
the cost of hardware measured
in millions, if not
tens of millions.
Chronicle is built
in a way that it
can search structured
data in under a second
over any volume of data.
And we really mean that.
To me, when I
first learned that,
it was a huge, huge innovation.
Even though, again, the
team that presented it
to me, the Chronicle
team at the time,
didn't really act as
if it's a big deal.
Of course, they're from Google.
Now, to me, being able to
search a petabyte of data
at subsecond speed does enable
a lot of investigative hunting
and detection use cases
in a very clean way.
Let me hit a few more
points on this slide
and then I'm going to go
into details on two of them.
We also notice that
in the past with tools
that collect the data
but don't make it useful,
the quality of data inside a
security monitoring platform
is a big challenge.
We decided to focus
very heavily on having
clean, enriched cross-correlated
data on our platform.
Here on the slide is highlighted
as intelligent data fusion.
That means we can
collect the data
and we can make it useful for
security operations use cases
by connecting
different data pieces.
Firewall data
connected to EDR data,
connected to server data,
connected to other data
sources you collect,
and, of course, the DNS
and DHCP as I highlighted.
We can also use this enriched
data to cross-correlate
with threat intelligence.
And they can do that both
historically and in real-time.
I'm going to make another point
about this in the next slide.
Also, we decided to
build a detection engine
into this platform that can
detect threats that are modern,
that appear today.
Of course, we would cover the
popular threats on that slide,
but we also want
to be future proof.
So if new types
of threats appear,
we would be able to
write detection content
to catch them.
Of course, self-managed
is a no brainer here
because it comes
with the cloud model.
Chronicle, after all,
is a SaaS platform.
So in that sense,
we don't suffer
from some of the complexities
of on premise SIEMs.
That's an obvious point.
How do customers use it?
I want to highlight
this very briefly.
Because, in many
regards, we are deployed
to extend another solution.
You may have a tool that you
use for compliance reporting,
for certain types of
workflow, but you're not
handling the volume well.
We do see Chronicle
deployed with other tools
to enhance this.
Of course, we also
see situations
where Chronicle is
deployed as their SIEM,
as the main security
information event management
tool for their SOC, for their
security operations team.
And in this case, they
migrate from a historical SIEM
to our platform.
In the middle, you
see another scenario.
In this case, we do see
customers deploy Chronicle to
on top of EDR.
There's some popular
EDR solutions
that produce telemetry
that's very useful for threat
detection and investigation,
but they don't actually
retain it for a year.
Now, you can refer to
some of the writing
we have done on the
Chronicle website
about how this is valuable.
I want to highlight the fact
that if you are investigating,
there's nothing
better than having
super quick access to one year
of data, or more than that.
Now, one thing I mentioned
briefly is detection.
And one of the big
surprises for me
when I first encountered
Chronicle technology
was that Chronicle relied a
lot on threat intelligence
and rules rather than, say,
machine learning as some
of the vendors.
Now, we do think that
machine learning is
a good approach for detection.
However, we also think that for
machine learning to work well,
you have to learn from
something, from real world
experiences of hunters,
incident responders, and not
just from the vendor labs.
So we have deployed Chronicle
with the rule-based detection,
with intel-based detection
that covers petabytes.
Can run on very high
quality enriched data
that we have so we can
match to enrich data,
say, IP addresses or DNS names,
even if threat indicators don't
match verbatim.
We also have a way to write
detection logic that's
not about writing queries
but about writing detection.
Writing detections here means
writing focused use cases
to detect threats, not just
extract data and then think
what it means.
This to me is kind
of a big deal.
[INAUDIBLE] is our
approach to this.
And you can see the
white paper on the site.
There's a lot of content
written on [INAUDIBLE]
and how it's evolved.
I did want to very
briefly remind you
about the productivity that
stems from subsecond responses
of search.
Again, my first encounter
with the platform
highlighted that if you
have tens of gigabytes
of data, hundreds of
gigs or petabytes,
the search speed
would be the same.
And that does allow
it to run queries,
run detection logic that is
not constrained by performance.
This to me is a very big point.
I don't want my SOC to be in
the performance optimization
business.
I want them to be in security
business, threat detection
business, not in, oh, my God,
my SIEM is too slow business.
I want them to run
detection logic instantly,
and Chronicle does enable that.
Now, as a technologist,
I am probably
more inclined to talk
about features, advantages,
capabilities, detection logic,
but for Chronicle, disruptive
economics is kind of a
big part of the attraction
of the platform.
To me, nobody was able to build
a software service monitoring
platform, a threat detection
platform that does not rely
on any volume pricing on data.
Admittedly, some of the
advantages you see here
are inherent with
any SaaS tools.
No infrastructure setup costs
and quite rapid searches.
But things like all the data you
want collected at a fixed cost
is unique.
And to me, this eliminates
many of the challenges
that modern SOCs face.
You want to have more data?
Have more data.
That's a decision that
should be based on the merits
and not on the costs.
This to me is what's changing
the landscape of some
of the SOC operations that
I've encountered, where
you can include the
data sources you want,
EDR, deeper service telemetry,
some of the cloud data sources.
And not pay anything
for any extra sources
is hugely liberating.
Now, if you're planning
the deployment of our tool,
of Chronicle, it's useful
to highlight a few items
when you're doing this.
Now, we do have tools to support
the total cost of ownership
analysis.
Admittedly, most
vendors do that.
But what you would see in our
case is that many of the TCO
calculations, many
of the TCO arguments,
because they derive their magic
from the predictable price
and decoupled from capacity,
compute, number of things
you run, so to me this is a
very big part of an attraction,
as I pointed out.
And again, some of the
things you see on this slide
are characteristics
of all modern tools
like, for example,
[INAUDIBLE] and APIs.
But some things on that slide
are very uniquely Google.
Of course, we rely on some
of the threat intel that
stems from Google's research
and Google's teams that
focus on identifying
threat actors,
but we also highlight
things like a rapid delivery
model, rapid deployment,
and, of course,
subsecond searches over
any source of data.
To me, many of the
clients and prospects
who are looking
at Chronicle have
evaluated things similar
to those in the slide
and decided to go
with the platform.
Let's get to the final
part of the presentation,
namely, the action items.
I would hypothesize that
many of the listeners
have some form of security
information event management
tool or a log management
tool, whether open source,
commercial, whether software
as a service or on-premise.
Now, one thing to note is
that if your approach today is
heavily on-premise based,
I think the time has
come to evaluate it.
Now, I would not pretend that
Chronicle is the only tool.
There is maybe a set of half a
dozen approaches, half a dozen
tools, vendors that started to
build software as a service,
SIEM, software as a service
threat detection tools.
Back in [INAUDIBLE] days,
I've looked at them,
and I found some of them
promising, some of them
not promising.
The idea is that the
on-premise approach starts
to slowly lose the importance.
And I would say, if I'm
planning my threat detection
platform of the future,
it would probably
be software as a service.
It will not be a legacy tool
deployed in [INAUDIBLE]..
It would not be a legacy
tool deployed on-premise.
It would be a native SaaS tool.
Advantages and the future
proofness of such tool,
if I may call it, coin a
term here, I just unmatch.
Now, you may think that
deploying SaaS-based, software
as a service-based tools, makes
sense for cloud environments.
And you would be right.
However, my point
is that it's also
useful for on-premise
environments.
Some of the advantages of SaaS,
lack of maintenance management
performance tuning, much
faster content updates,
much more rapid deployment
of detection rule,
normalization, other
types of advantages
are there and then here in SaaS.
In case of Chronicle, they are
coupled with super rapid speed,
backwards and forward to
indicate our matching,
and, of course, our unique
threat detection language.
Now, I did mention that
Chronicle is a software
as a service platform.
And I mentioned some of the
advantages of SaaS platforms
for monitoring and
threat detection.
Now, there would be
still a large group
of organizations that
would prefer some help even
with SaaS.
Now, as I said,
with SaaS you don't
need to operate the
servers, performance tune,
but you still need to
do things associated
with the typical security
operations workflow,
respond to alerts,
respond to incidents,
perform threat hunting.
What's useful to know
is that Chronicle
enables a decent number of
managed security providers,
or MDR providers, for
managed detection response.
And those providers
do take the last mile.
They help you with alerts.
They help you with defining
what type of detection to do.
They help you with
figure out what
threats you need to add to the
list of the popular threats,
which threats are
focused on your business.
So to me, the value of Chronicle
for managed security providers
is also huge because of
the cost model, the cost
of the detection content.
So to me, the useful
thing to keep in mind
is that if your
company thinks it's not
ready for deploying this--
I personally doubt it-- but
if you are in that bucket,
you can find a managed security
services provider, an MDR
provider, that runs Chronicle.
So you'd gain many of the
advantages of the platform,
but you'd also get help
with writing your SOC,
writing your
security operations.
Now, to conclude, I wanted
to highlight the fact
that Chronicle remains
a growing platform.
The product is very young.
So there would be things
that we will have to build.
We are still building
the workflow system.
We are still building a few
other things around detection.
And, of course, we want to
make our detection smarter
by using machine learning
and AI techniques.
The idea here is that we have
unique and strong advantages
in the platform
that I highlighted,
but we also remain to be a work
in progress to a large extent
as every good
product is, frankly.
So to me, what we
invite you to do
is not just to make
use of Chronicle today,
but to also grow with us.
Thank you very
much for listening.